[Music]
leaving a pencil in the sharpener hole
like an [ __ ] i'm going to need your
suggestions about my wardrobe asap
taking wardrobe suggestions from tom
also remember everyone
venezuela is a poor country that's
venezuelalist
pawnee has kind of a tricky history with
welcoming foreign visitors
i get that this is a sitcom but it's
also supposed to be based in the real
world and there is no chance a
government building in 2009 would have
this painting up for everyone to see
riding your bike or skateboarding in
traffic my mom's puerto rican
that's why i'm so lively and colorful
i'm taking a sin off for aubry plaza
because i can
and she's awesome everybody clean up
touching someone else's chest without
explicit consent
could you have your servant collector
backspace what did he call me a servant
he clearly said servant you heard him we
heard him
and satan heard him do we just uh
select the woman we desire oh haha let's
make light of women being treated like
sex objects
great choice parks and rec super great
kernston's
rubber nipples tastes like the real
thing they do not
american children are fattened more
efficiently than any other children in
the world
i mean they're like little basketball
false
they barely bounce and have you ever
tried to dunk one but i need thirty five
thousand dollars
and the city doesn't have enough money
in its budget i
do not understand rich people not
understanding budget restrictions or
rich people rubbing their financial
freedom in our faces or
just rich people venezuela is blessed
with massive oil reserves massive i mean
tremendous like do not believe
dutch disease everybody doing okay back
there comfortable
tom joins him at the park presumably by
driving another vehicle which would have
allowed one or two of the venezuelans to
join him in that car
sure we'd miss the three grown men
cramped in the back of a car joke but is
that really missing much
and four sided like dishes in my estate
why would you need four satellite dishes
one should be able to give you the same
amount of channels as another one that
goes beyond excessive
that's just stupid why are the trees so
small they're not that small
and there are plenty of normal-sized
trees all around them i get this tiny
tree is weird but it's clearly an
exception and not the rule
antonio nicely crunched with the crispy
rice removed
so a regular chocolate bar then also how
do you remove the tiny rice pieces
without destroying the bar entirely
you'd have to put the bar in your mouth
melt the chocolate and spit out the rice
puff then spit the chocolate into a
separate container and reform the saliva
infused chocolate into a new bar
not that i've tried cash money
i'm gonna make it rain making it rain
this is where you have your meetings
well the location rotates sometimes we
have them on the volleyball courts what
a strange way to say gymnasium
why don't you have hand dryers in the
park bathrooms
they're so much more sanitary than paper
towels spreading misinformation about
spreading germs
you overcook chicken also yeah i know
this is supposed to be over the top and
silly but this punishment really does
fit the crime
no one should have to eat dry chicken
did you hear that susie also this series
of
jail jokes goes on for all the some time
gummy bears
offering venezuelans gummy bears
venezuelans prefer haribo
everyone knows that tom he sent us all
his photos and quick time files i mean
quick time you have to see this place by
yummy i mean just gorgeous everything i
even hear in the clubs you can see
sliced alone
and a food so spicy and wonderful how
can one tell the food is spicy and
tastes good from quicktime files
i get why leslie is struggling to figure
out whether she should keep the money or
not but how is this her decision
if anyone in the actual department got
to make this call it'd be wrong but most
likely the parks department would have
to take this up with the mayor or an
appointed committee that would vote on
whether or not to keep
it and potentially vote on what the
money would be used for show doesn't
know how to government correctly
you should write this down what should
she write it down with the venezuelan
park committee keeps taking all the pins
viva pawnee viva mayor walter gunderson
good for leslie on having scruples but
they still have video for saying viva
chavez
and will probably just use that for the
edit so really you might as well just
kept the money
let it rain leslie knope hello my name's
nino and i found the perfect thing
lightning in a bottle blip they're not
that small
besides size doesn't matter i've been
working out i'm huge
cash money i'm gonna make it rain
[Music]
hey these chips are good
some nuts you would like my penis